et pour mieux comprendre le point de vue
des nations autochtones dans ce dossier
de la façon dont la crise a éclaté sur
les moyens à prendre pour prévenir ce
genre de réaction dans l'avenir je
reçois le grand chef de kanesatake et
serge axis simon grand chef bonjour
merci d'être avec nous les
commençons par ce qui a mis le feu aux
poudres info de meilleure expression
comment est-ce que le conflit entre le
britannique s'y retrouver dans ces
situations là commencent à dégénérer de
la soul c'est pas une situation qui date
d'aujourd'hui
ça fait longtemps que les pipelines
essaye de poser travaux des territoires
des autochtones dans l ouest comme dans
plusieurs autres nations du pays
et puis quand on voit les distilleries
arrivé avec son projet on parle souvent
avec le conseil d'abord on tape pour
toujours avec la nation en entier alors
c'est le pic aux mutations largeur en
cause la division et prononce rarement
ce avec une situation qu'on m'envoie à
ce moment qu'est ce que c'est pas quand
même un peu la responsabilité de la
communauté du conseil de bande de dire
on va amener tout le monde à l'attaquant
bien négocier ce qu'a clairement pas été
fait dans ce cas là oui les ouvertures
devraient ils devront être d'autres
efforts comme chez moi des efforts de
réconcilier à l'internet mais qu'on soit
traditionnel conseil d'avant ont vu la
même chose on veut protéger notre
territoire on veut économie éducation et
sud
alors je sais pas pourquoi ce qu'on a
des différences en principe à des
principes de base parce qu'on veut tout
la même chose
à quel point ce que les nations
autochtones ont une part de
responsabilité a porté sur l'absence de
communication parfois un triangle entre
les entre les chefs élus les chefs
héréditaire et sa communauté
oui on a un certain niveau de
responsabilité mais il faut voir aussi
le problème qui contrôle à travers le
pays c'est le colonialiste qui ont mené
à ces divisions lors des différents
centres additionnels et à conseil de
bande alors là il y aurait une
responsabilité du devoir du gouvernement
aussi qui ont imposé la colonisation le
la loi sur les indiens qui est hautement
paternaliste auquel britannique
qu'est ce qui aurait été la façon simple
de régler le problème à l'origine il ya
un public tout le monde soit sur la
table il a fallu qu'une consultation
comment quand vous auriez vite et se
vouent un premier temps avant que le
projet même approche
la porte la communauté que l'industrie
avec le gouvernement à les voir tous
ceux qui sont impliqués l'industrie
avait l'impression d'avoir rasé que la
bonne personne est assise avec les chefs
élus peas avaient ils avaient
l'impression d'avoir entre les mains une
entente
ce qui n'est pas le cas oui mais dans
chaque nation n'a de la diversité comme
ici au canada vous avez les niveaux
fédéraux provinciaux et municipaux dans
chaque nation encore on a deux
traditionnels on a le conseil de bande
alors on peut pas arriver faire des
changements qui va affecter tout le
monde à ce point là sans en discuter ça
avec tout le monde ça fout de qui parce
que si ce que c'est la compagnie qui a
pas fait l'effort d'aller voir tout le
monde joue c'est la communauté qui a pas
fait l'effort d'asseoir tout le monde à
la table le quand est venu le temps
discuter moi je dirais que c'est plus à
l'indicé lundi s'il veut absolument
pousser son projet et vont aller
toujours vers ce qu'ils vont dire qu'ils
sont plus aptes à dire oui or c'est s'il
est rationnel sont plus apaisée non non
on va laisser ça comme ça puis on va
aller avec ce qu'ils disent oui mais
c'est ce dépôt des projets qui sont à
haute valeur pour les gouvernements et
la société la société canadienne mais
pour nous c'est peut-être pas la même
valeur
les valeurs sont très importantes et
puis si nous on veut sauvegarder
l'environnement pour les générations
futures
et si ce projet la menace lits pour les
générations à venir il faut qu'on fasse
quelque chose on voit pas ça de la même
façon
comment on fait pour éviter pareille
situation dans l'avenir ce qui va y en
avoir d'autres des projets de gazoducs
et oléoducs qui vont devoir être négocié
entre la entre une entreprise et
communauté autochtone comment on fait
pour ne pas se retrouver dans la même
situation fait en sens à vos dans une
transition il faudrait réaliser même le
gaz liquéfié qu'on veut passer par le
web twitter le gaz le prix a baissé
tellement abord que les compagnies
peuvent pas faire d'argent et si on voit
les situations en asie le prix pas
prêtes à monter d'ici à demain
alors c'est une perte d'argent il
faudrait regarder la transition
énergétique le plus vite possible
puis là les prémices nation je crois que
vous allez avoir des bons partenaires
afin cette tradition ont pu accepter
d'autres projets qui sait à sauvegarder
l'environnement d'après vous ça passe
par là c'est dans la tradition que
l'ailier mon ce milieu rural
oui oui si vous voyez même les priorités
du gouvernement pour financer
ils sont à quoi 12 millions pour le
transit mentaux mais je n'ai vous si
vous avez plus 6 milliard de sous pour
adresser la pauvreté chez les premières
nations
il serait peut-être possible et a dit
oui sur le projet
s'il y avait une bonne économie et avait
de l'habitation éducation et futurs il
sera peut-être plus apte à des noms tous
ceux qui ont dit oui le moment ils
disent oui parce qu'ils sont très
pauvres c'est la pauvreté une raison
majeure de signer même pour des projets
dangereux
c'est pour ces points consentement qui
libre c'est comme un fusil à la tête
ces signes sur le peps et 5 pour avoir
de l'argent le la situation a suscité
des blocages sur la voie ferrée ou dans
des manifestations un peu partout à
travers le pays
à vous les pressions que ce genre de
geste là qui vient canet pacte
économique important au canada
est ce que ça vient un peu miné le
capital de sympathie des nations
autochtones auprès de la population
oui l'opinion publique que
souvent envie les contenus si on garde
des blocus à long terme comme ça je
crois que pour le moment on a fait notre
point on peut dire au gouvernement
si vous êtes intéressés par ces
problèmes de dents à l'ouest il ya
travail le pays avec nous et avec les
permis nation on va le faire encore pire
une fois pour plus longtemps vous avez
vécu vous êtes de grands chefs de calais
s'attaquer il ya déjà des années 80
c'est ça il ya eu il ya une situation
parce qu'il ya un explosif chez vous
quand vous regardez ce qui se passe ce
qui s'est passé cette semaine
est ce que ça vous inquiète un dieu
toujours brouillon un niveau
d'inquiétude sûr que les choses peuvent
dégénérer un certain point mais encore
il faudrait essayer de parler avec les
groupes qui sont impliqués dans les
blocus et de voix sur pour moyen
d'arriver à un compromis ensemble pour
voir s'ils ont pu régler le problème
mais c'est pour un bloc 1 à long terme
on a fait notre point là on s'assoit
puis on discute et on voit que l'on
revoie qu'est-ce qui va se faire bientôt
dans le futur à chelsea mot merci
beaucoup
les yeux